[Music]
honey mama what is it
I used to go with royal I was told to
take him into hotel
I said that he was an enemy of the state
take off your dress
and in exchange my mother look at the
doctor she needed instead they cut his
throat
there could be no witnesses so they gave
me a choice die or become a sparrow from
this day forward you will become spouse
weapons in a global struggle for power
you'll be trained in a psychological
manipulation you must learn to push
yourself beyond all limitation take off
your clothes when we are finished with
you the person you were in a longer
exist every human being is a puzzle of
need you must become the missing piece
and they will tell you anything you have
a gift you know how to survive this is
what you are meant to talk
loser traitor in the government his last
known contact is an American dead
cluster a very simple yesterday are we
going to become friends telling you want
a sparrow the only matter cause of what
you can do for them work with me and
make these men hey you are better at
this than any of us
your only problem is you have a soul
we can't trust in a word that comes out
of her mouth there's something else
we're now seeing
if he's compromised she will be
eliminated what have you done
you belong to them they won't ever let
go I'll find a way
[Music]